Nancy Rios: All right, so we want to, let you know that we are also figuring this out. This is a new learning experience for us as well. We're not, claiming that we know everything, but,
Nancy Rios: we do know that, we have set a few, like, principles, and the whole program is built, on them. So, our hope that is that you find this learning experience, worthwhile.
Nancy Rios: And as you guys know, with AI, it's changing fast, recruiters, hiring managers, they're all, sending mixed signals, and, this is why, this is kind of like the root as to why we built this program.
Nancy Rios: want to make sure it's of good service to you guys and good value. So, yeah.
Nancy Rios: So, a founder's mindset. So, here's kind of, like, one of our,
Nancy Rios: principles, and we want you to approach, like, the job search with the founder's mindset. So what exactly does that mean? So, it doesn't mean that you kind of just start a company and, you know, kind of start from scratch and
Nancy Rios: hustle hard, that's not really it. So a founder, doesn't just write, like, a perfect, plan and execute it, so they kind of troubleshoot, right? They make kind of, like, a small bet and, test it.
Nancy Rios: kind of watch what happens, what actually happens, and they kind of just, like, adjust as they're kind of… kind of like trial and error. Then they go again. So, this is kind of, like, something that we are going to be doing,
Nancy Rios: start with a hypothesis, experiment, and then adjust. That's kind of gonna be, like, the cycle of…
Nancy Rios: Career Intelligence during these, 6 weeks.
Nancy Rios: And so it kind of goes directly onto your, search that you will be doing. Your hypothesis is going to be, like,
Nancy Rios: I'm… I'm a strong fit for these roles that I am interested in and applying because of
Nancy Rios: And then you kind of, you know.
Nancy Rios: explain as to why you are a good fit for these roles. And so those would kind of be, like, your experiments. The applications that you do, the outreach that you are doing, the conversations that you have, maybe with, like, recruiters or mentors that you kind of meet along the way, hopefully, and, yeah.
Nancy Rios: So, it's not gonna be, like, easy, or, like, maybe it's… this is something that you've done, maybe it's not. So, we do kind of just ask that you, do…
Nancy Rios: as much as you, as you can, and even though it is going to be a little bit of uncertainty, just kind of keep moving. So, yeah.